our last session will be more of a
conversation than a series of
presentations and we're lucky to have
several veteran policymakers on circle
into the Middle East they've had
experience at top levels that are sort
of the Nexus I guess between
professional expertise and high politics
and I'm hoping they can comment both on
the substance of policy and what may be
practical and feasible given what they
know about how the American system works
I also hope that we might between their
comments and discussion with the
audience a little later on maybe get a
bit more into some issues that got less
attention this morning then they might
have if we had more time things like
energy policy and oil issues
counterterrorism things of that sort in
any case each of our panelists who I
won't bother describing their many
accomplishments since you had their BIOS
in your program but they'll each take
one or two minutes to put on the table
things they think are important to
consider and then we may elaborate on or
at least consider in the next hour and a
half so why don't we start with
Ambassador Murphy thank you to all right
two quick points first is that the
United States needs to find a more
productive way of dealing with the
non-state actors and I have in mind
particularly Hamas and Hizbollah we're
up we have operated for years on the
assumption they're both dedicated to the
destruction of Israel unwavering and
furthermore there just Iranian
instruments Clinton Secretary Clinton
recently expressed the formulation on
the Taliban which i think is a good
precedent that we shouldn't set
preconditions on
a dialogue we should set necessary
outcomes of that dialogue the backstory
for me on this is having been in the
Foreign Service for my career I watched
13 years go by when we observed our
pledge not to engage with the PLO from
75 to 80 8 might to question might our
engagement have affected influenced the
way the PLO developed but we we were not
in a position to do that at the end of
the day it didn't change our F at it
didn't change Israeli perceptions of RF
at so I I posed the question was it the
right course the other on oil policy
actually is about the Gulf I think we
need to rethink the issue of security
for energy supplies from the Gulf we've
had a military answer for every problem
and kind of lost sight of the free
market force that moves oil around the
world Iran has never shown any intent to
invade its neighbors or to shut Hormuz
has been some talk there was some talk
of that during the 80s but I don't see
on that score any quick change on Gulf
policy on the part of the United States
our friends in the peninsula are already
nervous enough about what they say we
did to Mubarak and the way we have
abandoned our friends over the years we
want to don't want to stir that point at
the moment those are my two points thank
you
let me just begin by saying I'm very
pleased to be here and looking forward
to this conversation I think in the the
one to two minute category is just
enough for me to say what I would be
very interested in speaking about during
this panel and there are so many issues
and one of them i would think that we'd
like to talk about it what are some of
the broad implications of the libyan
intervention for the region and i
certainly wouldn't make the case to that
what kind of government that results in
libya has major strategic implications
beyond libya but i think the
intervention itself raises a lot of very
interesting and important questions
among them have we learned any of the
lessons of iraq and afghanistan in the
last 10 years there too what does the
Libyan intervention tell us about
decision-making processes within the
Obama administration and the
administration's willingness to use
force 3 what are the implications of
this intervention for the energy and
bandwidth of the United States the EU in
the UN going forward for other endeavors
in the region and then finally I would
ask does this intervention set any kind
of precedent so I think that's my two
minutes Steve thanks to issues going
forward and this is both speaking as an
American from an American perspective
and also as a former government official
how does the u.s. develop a hedging
strategy at this point given the
apparently tectonic changes that have
taken place in the Middle East for the
first time in a long time of the US will
be dealing with a region characterized
by mobilize public opinion of friendly
regimes with less room for manoeuvre
possibly unfriendly regimes we ourselves
have reduced resources and polarized
politics well in the region structural
factors that created the recent
turbulence the ongoing
ones are not going away and I'm speaking
in particular the labor supply overhang
so I'm not being apocalyptic here you
know there may be opportunities as well
as risks for the United States but how
do you develop a hedging strategy and in
my former government official capacity
you know I'd want to add as a coda to
that point that the US government is not
particularly well constituted to do the
kind of contingency planning and
strategic planning that the development
of a hedging strategy would require the
second issue has to do with the
arab-israeli conflict what next there
the President President Obama seems to
believe that an agreement would be in
the United States strategic interest and
I think he also believes it would be an
Israeli interest or at least that's
probably implicit in his view but where
does where do the United States and
Israel go from here given the gaps
between the parties and tensions which
people talk about between the White
House and the Prime Minister's Office
well it's a range of things we can talk
about now or come back to as you wish
and please so the panel's we'll all jump
in with each other whatever point they
have something to say let me just ask
one question that a little surprise has
hardly been anything said about today
and that's counterterrorism and how it
relates to the region simply because
that's been such a priority in the
United States in the last 10 years
whether an exaggerated priority or not
maybe another issue but in any case
that's how many Americans think about
her care about the Middle East are there
any ways in which counterterrorism does
not comport easily with the rest of
American interests in the Middle East or
anything to be said about how all the
issues we talked about this morning
would bear on on that for Americans who
are primarily interested in it there may
be closer to the subject the others on
the panel yes well I guess as a preamble
to my um kind of fudging answer that I'm
quickly trying to develop while I
deliver my preamble is that you know to
the extent that the Terrorism that the
United States is worried about is you
know jihadism the epicenter seems to
have shifted from the Middle East
elsewhere and it seems to be primarily
South Asian and European phenomenon
actually fits well with dick bullets you
know Islam view from the edge kind of a
take on the history of the Islamic world
in any case I don't see at the moment a
huge of jihadist threat from within the
region that we're talking about now you
know the changes that could emerge that
could evolve could open up the scope for
the re-entry of al-qaeda into the region
this could happen just because security
services are distracted and when
security services are distracted and the
ties with the United States are not such
that the u.s. is in a position to
maintain constant pressure and the
sometimes the technical support that
countries where these activities are
happening might need well you know
there's there's ample opportunity I
suppose but so far we really haven't
seen this now I myself of course from a
counterterrorism perspective will
greatly miss our departed and threatened
friends you know whether you know Hosni
Mubarak or for that matter should he
depart muammar qaddafi who in the wake
of the pan am 103 settlement took you
know a good and verifiable steps against
jihadists in in Libya I will also not be
happy to see just on counterterrorism
grounds Ali Abdullah Saleh depart Yemen
if indeed he is going to depart because
restoring or rebuilding counterterrorism
ties with the y amantes is not going to
be all that easy as I think secretary
gates indicated the other day in
comments possibly to to the press so
there you go
let me just add to that in a somewhat
consistent manner and I certainly don't
want to be perceived as being alarmist
about an imminent threat from al Qaeda
from North Africa but let me just remind
you of President Obama's rationale for
our strategy in Afghanistan you'll
remember his speech of 2009 where he
talked about the very specific and
limited American interest in removing
the threat from al qaeda al qaeda posed
yet he proposed a very ambitious
strategy and those of us who try to you
know match ends with means realized well
the rationale here are the potential
rationale is that if al Qaeda thrives a
nun governed territory then you need to
govern territory to make sure that
al-qaeda doesn't have a place to thrive
and so that I think is the connection
between the fairly specific goal in
Afghanistan and the fairly ambitious
strategy and so what does that mean for
the specific question about what we're
seeing today in the Middle East and
certainly if al Qaeda is not in some of
these countries right now what these
countries turn into in the coming months
or years has major implications for how
attractive they may be for al Qaeda that
will continue to seek out uncovered
space certainly a weak state states
experiencing civil conflicts these are
more conducive for terrorist groups to
operate and inhabit than states that
have very strong institutions and we're
clearly moving into a period where a lot
of these countries will at best have
weak institutions and quite possibly in
some cases will have no institutions so
it may not just be a case that Steve
suggests about a distracted security
service it could well meet be a case of
no security service I just say be
careful that we don't continue the
obsession with terrorism that we've had
far longer than 10 years at least back
to the bombing of our embassy in Beirut
in 83 Gaddafi is just the less
just one to say that all of his
challenges are because of al-qaeda and
without him al Qaeda would sweep North
Africa that's you know his defensive
stance if you will just as Farouk shadow
the Syrian vice president said the day
or so ago all of our problems because of
agents working for well our problems are
because of al Qaeda which is working for
the United States and Israel just be
careful of such defenses if this is that
truly the nature of a conversation i do
want to point out the distinction
between what you're saying which i agree
we can't justify all of our policies and
actions in the lens or through the lens
of counterterrorism but it's different
to say that we should continue to
support people like Mubarak and Qaddafi
based on counterterrorism arguments and
to be cognizant of the fact that their
removal particularly in case of Qaddafi
without any replacement regime does
create a different possibility for
threat so they're not these are two
slightly different arguments I've just
add one thing which is of that on the
social science of radicalization how
much I don't know a whole lot but this
is Columbia you know the one the one
thing that you can tease out of the
literature is that the absence of space
and opportunity for political
participation is a serious factor in
radicalization to the extent that these
societies do become more participatory
in the in the political domain there
might be a corresponding decrease in
radicalization which would lead you know
to the kind of violence that that we
fear I also didn't hear much about Iraq
earlier today and
if you go back not many years that was
dominant issue in u.s. security policy
at least we're not hearing more about it
because it all worked out okay or is it
getting lost in the shuffle because
there's too much else going on and may
we be brutally surprised by events there
partially because it's getting a little
depressing to see Iraq drift back
towards a very autocratic model as
Maliki gathers more and more power and
alienates some of the other parties and
sex in his country it's probably because
we American public has pretty much made
its mind up we're getting out of there
as fast as we can decently or even
indecently do Megan you've been close to
this sure um let me somewhat predictably
make the case to you that I think we are
meaning we the United States is making a
pretty big mistake and how it is
handling the Iraq situation right now in
a sense of allowing it to go off the
radar in such a such a dramatic fashion
I for one am still thankful every time I
pick up the new york times in iraq is
not on the front page it's still a
source of joy for me but let me give you
just a couple of reasons why I think
Iraq actually should matter to the
United States more than ever the first
is we're looking at in the course of a
few months a dramatically changed Middle
East we all don't know what will come
next I think that's consensus of
everyone who spoke but we do know it
won't look like the past and so many of
America's friends are or people who were
considered reliable allies are no longer
in power blue barks gotten others are
certainly have other priorities the
Saudis are going to be much more
internally focused now than they have
been and so suddenly we're looking at a
real shortage of governments in the
Middle East that are sympathetic to US
interests and goals and the Iraqis for
which the United States has laboured
intensively spent almost a trillion
dollars lost nearly
five thousand people on 30 thousand
wounded now this is a place where we
have made a substantial investment
already and we would be wise to
capitalize on investment if we're going
to spend a lot of effort and time
potentially money energy political
capital in rebuilding Olivia why
wouldn't we spend more time on an Iraq
which we've already made a huge
investment and just again not to give
you a whole lecture on this but just
very briefly other things we talked a
little tiny bit about economics now the
future of the Middle East in order to
address a lot of these fundamental
problems these countries are going to
have to address the big economic
problems we've all talked about and
identified in terms of demographics and
unemployment what's going to be the
driver these countries are unlikely to
compete with China economically so we're
going to have to look to something that
looks like better regional integration
and I think Iraq could be a driver of
that and it's particularly given its
energy resources and its central
location and that gets me to another
reason why Iraq matters more than ever
if you were to pick up most of the
projections of big energy institutions
or companies you would find that looking
out to 2020 and 2030 every single one of
them has in their projections that Iraq
is going to at least triple its current
production of oil or double or triple
now when I've asked some of these
analysts well that's an interesting
assumption to make what if that doesn't
happen well then you know then the
world's ability to meet rising demand at
a reasonable price is severely
undermined so from the energy
perspective we're all nervous about
talking about Iraq and oil in the same
sentence but the reality is it should be
a very big concern in Iraq could allow
the world to meet growing demand without
an economic crisis so in the last point
I'll mention was just in the last panel
I think we forgot to acknowledge that
Iraq's government is in fact an Islamist
government and I am hesitant even say
this I'm the last person who's who will
say that Iraq should be a model for the
rest of the Middle East but there
certainly are things we can learn about
political reconstruction from Iraq that
will be applicable to other countries
let me just press you a little on this
you talked about capitalizing on
investment and all the cost we paid and
O'Connor's might say those are sunk
costs and you don't make decisions on
the basis on cost but on the marginal
cost of success going forward right so
what are you assuming about the likely
marginal cost to the United States of
ensuring success what do we have to do
and what would it cost to get you over
that anxiety right um I'll probably
never be over that anxiety I will
probably always be a little bit worse
about working while to make that gamble
right way to cut lost short but it's a
very good question and this is a very
different conversation than if we were
having it in 2006 where I think most
people were of the view that whatever
kind of commitment one that it probably
wasn't possible to turn Iraq around and
two if it were possible it wasn't worth
the cost that it that it would that
would be required we're in a very
different situation Iraq is is as
certainly as our first pay our second
panel mentioned not you know free and
clear there are concerns and problems
about increasing consolidation of power
by the Prime Minister and there are lots
of other issues that are still not
resolved in Iraq that said I think that
Iraq's ability to manage the remaining
problems will one it will of course have
to be done largely by Iraqis but to
continued US involvement on the margins
could i think and i guess i don't have
enough time to make this a fully
compelling argument but could make the
difference and in that case the question
is well how much american involvement is
required and let me just point to the
status of forces agreement which is due
to expire the end of this year which as
most of you or many of you may know
requires that all american troops are
withdrawn from iraq by the end of this
year this was a security agreement that
was negotiated under the Bush
administration but you know has been
embraced by the Obama administration by
all accounts both sides are just going
to let that agreement expire and by the
end of this year we will go from 48
thousand troops in Iraq to
a to maybe a few hundred this number i
think is insufficient for what iraq
could use from the United States not
only for the tasks that the moderator of
the for the second panel laid out but
also for the psychological dimension of
having having an American force there
that gives different parties a higher
level of confidence in the political
future of the country all for different
reasons so I think that in relate to sum
up I think the investment by the United
States would be comparable small it
would be both in terms of a small number
of existing troops much less than with
the 50,000 we have a continued
allocation of resources by Congress for
civilian civilian efforts in Iraq which
is not forthcoming and then the
administration willing to invest
political capital in staying engaged in
Iraq at Vice President Biden's level but
also above turn any other views in Iraq
maybe the last kind of general question
I ask the three of you is if you put
aside questions how naive it is to think
in terms of big changes in policy if in
your dreams you could make one major
change that it's at least maybe remotely
feasible and things would work right in
the governmental process one major
change away from business as usual as
we've known it is there anything you
think is a lost opportunity
and all of these issues and if not
should we be reassured or depressed no
how about dessert ooo prophecy receiver
I think you know what we're seeing on
the Arab side at this moment and it may
not last is the end of fear you know
they stood up in Tahrir Square they
stood up in Tunis they're up there in
Libya and Yemen and even in Syria so you
know that's a big change the regime's
were able to repress very effectively
some more viciously than others but
we've been we've heard a lot of fear
today I think about our the American
position these are the visiter the
terrorist groups and in Israel's fear
I'd like to think we can find ways to
lower the level of fear on our side and
keep it lower in the region but how
could we help if if we can things go in
the right direction and the upheavals in
the Middle East or are we just doomed to
screw things up if we try to push things
in the right direction well we're still
just at the beginning of the beginnings
people have used the word revolution
repeatedly we may be seeing a series of
revolts which will put us back where we
started a year or more from now so
everyone's going to be a bit cautious I
think can rightly cautious on our side
r us say something big um I don't know
if you want to move ahead I you know
change the subject no no i'd like to
respond to those two questions the first
about if we could change anything and I
would say on the first front what do I
think would make the functioning of our
government better on the foreign policy
front right now I think it would be the
clear articulation of a strategic
framework for the United States
important policy what what are the first
principles that we're acting on in the
world and how and what can our partners
or our enemies expect from us so I think
kind of a clear articulation of that
would be helpful the second point about
what can we do to help the region and
this is a this will sound like a boring
technocratic answer but perhaps one of
you will remember me saying it in the in
the months or years ahead one of the
real lessons from Iraq and Afghanistan
is just the real paucity of civilian
power we have our ability to do things
outside of our military but to do things
with our diplomats and our aid and our
development work those types of things
these countries are going to need
enormous technical and political
assistance as they rebuild their country
I spent about two years in Iraq helping
the Iraqis do things like right there
Constitution argue and formulate an
electoral law all these kinds of things
what is a super majority needed for in
Parliament what is it not all of these
questions are highly fraught both
politically but also just you know how
are things going to function the Iraqis
have a system now which is geared
towards consensus because of the nature
of it being a divided society the
consequences that they've experienced
enormous amounts of gridlock and getting
things done and that's had implications
so these kinds of issues how do you
build institutions from scratch these
are very very hard questions obviously
the United States does not have an
appropriate role to tell countries how
to do this and we have to be very
sensitive about how we help countries
tackle these issues but I do think that
if we could build our civilian capacity
and find ways to help countries that are
interested in our help that that would
be tremendously useful over the years
ahead we asked for a strategic framework
and my business I hear that a lot and
who can deny that it's a desirable thing
that isn't possible and if the president
delivered a speech articulating a clear
coherent strategic framework and you say
to give friends and allies and others or
adversaries an idea what to expect from
us could the United States deliver on a
coherent strategy is our system really
geared to following through with that
kind of strategy am I being too cynical
implying well I think I think it would
be difficult if I can revert to what i
seriously would like to see different
okay in terms of a glittering dream you
know shimmering vision it would be a
bipartisan foreign policy and
in elite if I can use the term in the
technical sense that shared a worldview
and was able to support advice and
contribute to a government attempting to
implement a coherent foreign policy and
this is something of course that we have
not had in the US for a very long time
but you know and and I don't think
frankly at this point it will ever be
reconstituted or at least not in my
increasingly diminished like time but
that's what I think in a kind of utopian
sense would really be good and it gets
to your point about implementable atiba
cuz you know the ability of the
government to implement a policy depends
largely on by in by in a leap across the
board because public opinion cues off a
lead consensus and distances for that
matter so that's that's what I would
that's what I would like but don't
expect to see Richard on I think this is
a moment at least where we can talk
about our values about our principles
the audience for our specific ideas is
going to be suspicious when it comes to
building the right kind of government we
who supported the dictators are friends
for so long the the hearing of our ideas
in many years is going to be limited
what we can do is encourage business
encourage investment in those countries
none of the new boys are going to have a
magic wand to create a million jobs next
year nor a week and some of the problems
we're having ourselves
but move money move investment into
those countries that are going to be a
job intensive which the oil business
never has been never will be any other
basic points we ought to toss around
before we ask the audience they want to
know those are your chance to get at
veteran policy makers and pin them down
let me follow up on some of the
conversation gift had and I wonder where
you think about what you change really I
think relate to Steve's point about
bipartisan ship but I wonder that you
know the three of you have all had
serious policymaking experience
essentially the executive branch if you
just focus for a bit on that and think
of sort of can this be saved that is
kinda can we put together a foreign
policy making machinery even in the
executive branch that you know brings
together the disparate agencies in a way
that can funnel information and
decisions to the President and then
implement them in a way that has a
Markham of coherence and I you've all
been in different administrations but
the people i talk to always the
overwhelming emotion is frustration how
difficult it is to get anything done and
we talked to academics who have studied
with some care but then going in at
medium level and ask them what is
surprising the the thing they say in
addition to really how how skillful and
how dedicated most of the people they
deal with it how frustrating it is and
how the machinery just doesn't work so
if you have your magic wands can you fix
the machinery for us any specific pet
tweaks you'd make it
maybe well the current complaint as I
get it out of Washington from well the
usual source of complaints the State
Department people is that the National
Security Council is far too large far
too much of a policymaking body rather
than recommending or making sure the
president has all feasible choices
fairly placed in front of him so I guess
the idea would be keep some of the hands
off the button but hasn't that been a
complaint for 40 years now it has been
is getting worse worse than under
Kissinger well the least was a one-man
children but we on this question are we
moving off anything you want to say
about it but look I think it's a kind of
a damned if you do and damned if you
don't situation because the interagency
process is you know is a curse in that
it yields you know only satisficing or
at bests you know sub optimal policy
solutions because it's very difficult to
rope in all the agencies you need and
get them to agree on a policy option or
set of options that's audacious on the
other hand when you cut the interagency
process out for example and so as to do
something audacious you wind up with
something like Iraq that was arguably a
problem you know a kind of a problem
child of this of this process now I mean
I suppose you rock could have turned out
well and who knows it may yet in the
fullness of time but you know it was an
audacious thing that was able to happen
because government machinery was
sidelined in s and so you know I think
take your pick do you want to take the
risk of really bad things happening or
do you want this kind of continuing
stream of highly reactive very tactical
and unambitious you know policy outcomes
the other thing you know that I would
look to would be some intelligence
reform we were talking about this a
second ago you know we can talk about it
more but I think that's any real issue
just if I can jump in on the interagency
one of the things that I'm pretty
certain about is I will never hear
anyone in government say the interagency
is working well you know it's always
interagency is broken I think that that
we can expect and the question is just
you know how broken is the interagency
and I'm sympathetic to what Steven just
described which is maybe you either have
to settle for really mundane incremental
decisions that never have the
possibility of changing a strategic
picture in a fundamental way if you work
through the bureaucracy or run the risk
of having decisions that turn out to be
really poor decisions if you circumvent
that bureaucracy and I think you know
there's certainly plenty of examples to
support either of those propositions but
I do think that we have learned a little
bit about the conditions that are
required to make the interagency work in
a way that actually can produce a good
decision and when I mean a good decision
a set of prescriptions or a strategy
that is actually related to the
situation in the problem at hand and
just drawing on my own personal
experience I would look back to not the
first decision on Iraq in 2003 but the
second big decision on Iraq which was
that related to the surge that was the
the fullness of that decision making
process by President Bush I think was in
part a reaction to the the real poor
quality of the decision-making process
by the same president in 2003 and
a little bit of a learning curve but not
to go into that entire process but just
to say that there are two things I think
that do make the interagency more likely
to produce something useful and bigger
than incremental or one really clear
strategic guidance from the president
and so you know that that would be the
first thing and that's not always there
in any administration but that's
probably the most important thing and
then to is a willingness to keep the
question open for at least a little
while one of the things and I'm sure we
all everyone in this room who's been in
any government has battled with is just
the desire for an answer you know you're
never looking at something that's not a
problem and so when you're looking at a
problem people want answers in the case
of Iraq or Afghanistan which are the two
places I worked on people wanted answers
yesterday and so the real challenge is
to get people to keep the question
opened up long enough that you actually
can look at different options and then
thirdly and related to that is just the
openness of very senior people to
re-examine assumptions and that's a very
very hard thing to do when you have been
invested in a policy or a strategy
particularly if you're the president
you're personally invested in it to
actually be willing to sit down and say
maybe the assumptions upon which we
based our strategy are wrong and we need
to re-evaluate them and I think Gary
sick made a really interesting point
this morning when you said we're at a
point we really need to sit down and
look at the assumptions that have been
the basis of our strategy towards this
region so I'm sure that the people
working in government have their hands
overflowing but hopefully they will find
time in the coming weeks to really say
we can't deal with every country only on
its own we have to deal with the
monotone but we also have to deal with
them in a larger strategic framework and
that really warrants a fairly extensive
long-term strategy discussion in the
government that begins with looking at
those assumptions let me just ask
Stephen Megan since they're veterans of
the NSC staff whether they have any more
sort of direct defense against the
criticism we heard from Dick Murphy I'm
have occasionally about sort of the NSE
doing too much taking too much on are
there ways from your experience that you
would see the more active or demanding
role of the NSC staff solving problems
that more traditional deference to the
department's would have not solved
especially I'm Middle East issues are
there ways in which that cuts one way or
the other or is this just not something
you generalize about it's when when you
get a very kind of interventionist or
proactive NSC it's usually because the
West Wing sees the agencies as being too
hopelessly wrapped up in their own
bureaucratic processes is to be unable
to produce what's required so I this is
irrespective of administration this is
just you know what happens so one way
that you kind of get around the
sclerotic you know behavior of agencies
is to just move things up to the NSC now
as you move things up to the NSC you
moving increasingly small scale and
trivial decisions up to a very high you
know level which then in turn jam znse
oh so you know you really get kind of a
log jam but that's that's how you get
you know these problems between the NSC
and the agencies on the peace process
you know it's even more complicated
because you have a state department that
for the most part never had the peace
process done within its own bureaucracy
the way the structure of the
organization would have dictated so the
peace process was taken out of the Near
Eastern affairs bureau and moved into a
separate compartment you know for
reasons you know we can we can talk
about and the tickler if he can you know
probably you know describe pretty well
if you felt like it but so there are
peculiarities some of your cratic kind
that affect every level you know of
government can create the kinds of
problems that were discussing next well
I'm not a junkie on political
bureaucracy but I find it very
fascinating but I wouldn't want to turn
more directly to the question about
strategic guidance in the bigger picture
we talked about you talked about
counterterrorism you raised that but but
the the broader problem in the
relationship between a policy of
counterterrorism a policy of
counterinsurgency it seems is something
that needs to be dealt with in your memo
strategic or speech or whatever a
strategic alliance we've got some real
problems particularly for the UA
us-israel relationship because the is
there the question first questions is
there a contradiction or is there one of
the real problems between
counterterrorism policy and
counterinsurgency policy I mean when you
have to think about nation building you
know sometimes you have to compromise I
other things and the second point has to
do with we went from this superpower
world that we all grew up in to a much
more diffused world you know where we
went from a g2 really was no g2 to a g7
to a g2 a g20 when we run the risk of
having a g0 because of the question of
us leadership where are we what kind of
role is the United States going to play
in this post to Superpole how many how
many other poles do we come in and and I
think that that will be a real question
for your strategic alliance whether it's
g20 or g3 again anyone let me get just
responded with two things which I think
are related but may not get the entirety
to the entirety of your comment first
when I'm thinking about this strategic
framework I'm really thinking about
things at a fairly high level so that
that if you were to go ask a very
well-informed American or just an
American that say read the New York
Times every day and you ask this
question what what does President Obama
think about what kind of world is
conducive to US interests and what is
the role in the United States and
shaping that world or what are
legitimate reasons to you for America to
use force in creating that world are
sustaining that world so these are
pretty big grand strategic questions but
they are ones that at the end of the day
you would like to think that there's
some touchstone a you know whether or
not you agree with it you'd like to
think that there was some sense of what
kind of world does the US feel it wants
to live in it doesn't mean it has to be
a world where the the United States is a
hegemonic power but it just you know it
might mean that this is a world that's
good for the u.s. so those are the kinds
of questions that i think i would like
to see some sort of answer for just to
get to your point about counterterrorism
just two quick points one is i don't
think that counterterrorism could ever
be the guiding principle of any kind of
grand strategist simply because it is a
negative vision I think I mean there's
all kinds of reasons why you want to
have a grand strategy but one of them is
so you know how to allocate scarce
resources one of them is so you can make
sense to people and you can mobilize
people your own citizens and I think
trying to mobilize people around a
negative vision i think is ultimately
not going to be very fruitful on the
point of counterterrorism versus counter
insurgency I know we're getting a little
bit further away from the the
meet of this panel but I would simply
propose to that these things are not
opposites that they're actually there's
a huge overlap between counterterrorism
and coy Nina that there's actually we're
talking about more of a spectrum than
two distinct ways of acting it's very
hard to do coin without CT it's very
hard to do CT without some element of
coin but that might be a conversation
for offline problem with it's not really
I guess with counterinsurgency but that
takes us into the role of a we know best
how you should shape your government and
how you should develop your country and
that is increasingly challenged and
presented can I tell my Saddam story now
okay it was in the days when he was
writing very high fighting Iran and we
were doing our best to keep arms from
getting to Iran and meeting which
happened about a year for some months
after iran-contra burst out he made the
remark to me that America treats the
third world like an Iraqi peasant treats
a new wife leaving me with the obvious
rejoinder oh and yes he said it's three
days of tea and honey that off to the
fields for life he thought that was you
know great his foreign minister nearly
fell off his chair the humor and meeting
pretty well broke up at that point but
he was saying something which hated as
he was and still is he speaks were a lot
of the third world at least in the Arab
world so Connor countered that since
counter terrorism is more easily
understood and accepted than
counterinsurgency costs a lot less money
counterinsurgency I
see it at all as telling people how to
make their countries work I see it as
creating an environment which you allow
others to do the work of building their
institutions that's certainly what the
framework was in two thousand and seven
and eight and nine in Iraq is the
counterinsurgency moving into a
stabilization force and the idea was
simply and again I don't want to take us
too far off and tangent that I would
like to go but may nakita one is going
but simply this this issue of you know
needing to have a certain amount of
security in order to build institutions
and I think that is a lesson that that
we've learned and it's a lesson that
unfortunately we look like we meaning
the international community could be
learning it over and over and over again
I was just my experience of marriage I
would also like to refocus the talk from
interagency decision making to what
should be the focus of American strategy
and I was struck by dick Murphy's
account of Iran I would think that Iran
is a much more destabilizing force I
mean Hezbollah destabilizes the Lebanese
State Hamas certainly made life made um
on State Building for the Palestinians
much more difficult and Hamas played
quite a big role in destabilizing Egypt
and we think of the breach of 2008 and
the point that i want to make and ask
you is shouldn't american one of the
American aims in the coming years given
the internal flux within States is to
promote stability between states because
the more flux you have within States
usually there is over there spillover
and it makes State Building for all the
states in the region going through
Flux even more difficult so that iraq
probably one of the problems that Iraq
is going to have is these this
destabilization may be in back lane and
maybe in Syria it's going to make life
so shouldn't an American strategy be
more forceful against possibly possible
d stabilizers like not possible but
contemporary d stabilizers like Iran and
make sure that other states whatever
they're going through internally do not
do not sort of some create tensions
amongst neighboring states as a
strategic goal of American policy it's
it's a very fine goal the when I look at
his bola I think of the years the
centuries that the Shia of Lebanon were
kept in the third class citizenship
category and Lebanon is paying for that
now they've sensed a chance to come
center stage or close to it an Iran is
helping the problem in Lebanon and his
mother is that Lebanon was the proof
that the Iranian Revolution was valid it
could be exported it was welcomed and
they made quite an investment there and
still still do apparently in terms of
arms supplies but is hizbollah a purely
a catspaw avi ron I don't think so his
bail is looking for a place in its Sun
in Lebanon is it going to take over the
state of lemon I don't think so on god
preserve whoever takes over the state of
Lebanon but the Shia it's not going to
become a Shiite Republic convinced to
that so as what we're watching is the
struggle of the the Shia and they found
in his male leadership
presented by Monisha in Lebanon but
still a leadership which is pulling them
up and getting them some benefits that
they were not getting from the
government of Lebanon or they would say
more broadly around the way around the
region Hamas it's another case they're
happy to have the arms from Iran but
their their focus is not serving Iran
its leading the Palestinian political
forces and they face a lot of resistance
so strategy has to deal with Lebanon
with Hamas Hezbollah as to some degree
separate problems from Iran and see if
we've been fond of the term weaning
these elements away from Iran see if can
be done and we haven't given that idea
much space to run yet that's what that's
all I'm saying I don't know if it'll
work but I think we went out of our way
to isolate Hamas after the elections in
full support of Israel and in retrospect
I'm not sure that was a bright thing to
do on either of our parts because Hamas
is not clearly a lot weaker today then
we thought it was going to be five years
ago when we adopted that policy after
the elections all I'm saying is keep
let's keep our minds open keep our eyes
open to other ways of dealing with Iran
on the one hand and with the so-called
instruments of Iranian power I think
those instruments have a life of their
own and desires of their own
thank you this question is addressed to
mean Sullivan you post the four
questions and I don't know if you
actually went over them but I wanted
particular to bring about what I think
are the two most important of them which
are the because actually one of them has
already been in touch with the decision
making but have the u.s. learned from
Iraq and Afghanistan but I think this is
it is necessary to two in the
independence of windows or group error
Facebook etc to refer to Iraq one dot
zero or that is 91 when Bush the first
encouraged the rebellion of the Shiites
and then abandon them and and allowed
the ED love sedan to Massacre them is
that what you were referring to that
that that Obama should have basically
have done the same or and regarding
Afghanistan I would again very backwards
technological abilities of fine semantic
play at vanished on what 10 again when
when the US ink under the policy of for
the enemy of my enemy is my friend no
matter whether they will become very
soon nite nite my enemies leave and then
leaves Afghanistan to their own to their
own and then has to deal with the
consequences in Afghanistan to and a
second the president the president sorry
which is a practically the same
president or president that what worry
you
okay i'm going to inevitably try to put
too much into this answer but that's
because you put too much into your
questions so it's only fair um I know
that I was not certainly was not making
that inference about when the lessons
from Iraq and Afghanistan that it should
have been to let a humanitarian crisis
unfold I think if we look at Iraq in
1991 and say whether the lessons from
that Iraq there certainly there
certainly are some one would be about
how to build and maintain a coalition
perhaps most interestingly would be the
lesson about when in whether to go
beyond a UN mandate for regime change
and that's something that's in the
future these of Olivia but certainly one
of the things that I think gives a lot
of people pause is this lack of clarity
over is the United States dedicated to
unseating Kadafi or dedicated to the
implementation of the UN resolution and
that is not clear at this point and I
think that was certainly one thing that
the HW Bush administration was very
clear on visa V Iraq 1.0 i was actually
referring to the Iraq the post 2003 Iraq
and there are many many lessons I mean
obviously these are very different
situations that said I think there are
many broad lessons that are applicable
and I'll just mention one simply in the
interest of time and that would be and
this is a lesson from Iraq post 2003 and
from Afghanistan post 2001 and that
would be that there are very serious
limitations to the use of military force
in terms of reaching your objectives
that I mean this is the lesson from a
decade working with people in those two
theaters and going to many conferences
which many of you have attended that is
probably the lesson with the greatest
amount of consensus that military force
in itself cannot achieve that much and
that it always has to be coupled with
other tools of diplomacy economics other
things and so that's why it's a bit
striking to look at what has happened
just in the last 10 days or so with
Libya
and to think about how much the
conversation is around simply the use of
force and how little discussion there is
about the politics that will inevitably
have to follow so how is it possible to
really say that the u.s. engagement in
this endeavor can be days and not weeks
when in fact it may be that the military
part of this engagement is relatively
short although I I wouldn't even put my
money on that but it may be but even if
it is we know that before what happens
in Libya can be successful from the
perspective of Libyans or anyone
international community it has to
involve a very big political piece in
terms of you know what comes next
another lesson would be don't remove a
regime without having an idea of what
comes next or at least what you're
willing to commit to the process of what
comes next and we can look at
Afghanistan and talk about that so there
really are a lot of lessons which it
doesn't appear that we have fully
internalized them some of the lessons do
have to do with the decision-making
process and I won't go back into that
but certainly you know we've learned the
hard way about what makes for good
decision-making and and what makes for
bad decision making but I would say the
lesson about the limited utility of
military force on its own is the number
one there's a there's a Marine Corps
colonel in the movie full metal jacket
it makes a statement that inside every
Vietnamese is an American waiting to get
out and I think correlated to this is
our Constitution and its evolutionary
nature Bill of Rights and all that are
we sort of doomed to be handicapped
forever dealing with the rest of the
world trying to create America's while
the Chinese and Russians being more
pragmatic sort of steal our lunch every
place
there's nobody using quiet if nominated
I will not run I don't think that we're
we're doomed in this sense because I
think that you know the number of cases
in which this is going to arise is
really rather limited you know it's not
clear as Megan was saying what us
objectives are let alone what NATO you
know objectives are in Libya at this
point because they're too many players
involved right now and ice in this was
all going to be resolved actually and by
President Obama's speech today was it
today tonight tonight yeah so we're
looking forward to that the situation in
Libya developed of course extremely
rapidly and a welter of pressures you
know on the administration on Washington
developed equally rapidly so you had
decision-making taking place without the
you know clearly in crisply articulated
war aims that you'd like to see having
said all that you know I don't see the
United States replicating its engagement
and and commitment and investment as it
were in Iraq in Libya that's not going
to happen and it's not going to happen
in Yemen where the administration I
think it's already ruled out the use of
ground forces so you know that's that's
not going to happen and as a number of
I'm not an expert on these things but a
number of speakers have already said
well informed speakers that we that is
the u.s. is going to be pulling out of
Afghanistan and Iraq more or less on the
schedule that the President had
stipulated already and that is a
consequence in the case of Iraq of the
agreement that the United States and and
and Iraq have forged on the withdrawal
of forces so you know beyond those
places it's not clear where you would
see the
it states doing all this again and I
think as scary sick pointed out earlier
today the appetite you know in the
United States is not such that an
administration would leap to the
opportunity to reengineer another
society imagine that you are sitting in
a conversation with the leader of a pro
america and arab al I say someone from
quaid or Qatar Bahrain or the Emirates
we've been Jordan with Saudi Arabia and
the leader is telling you asking you the
following question I've been observing
American strategy and policy in the
Middle East in the last two years and
this is what I see American was drawn
from Iraq American withdrawal from
Afghanistan American inability to
prevent Iran from acquiring nuclear
weapons American stabbing one of its
most reliable ally in the Middle East eg
in the back stabbing mubarak in the back
and if there's no such thing as power
vacuum in the Middle East and if the
United States is on its way out and if
Iran is on its way in why wouldn't I
make steps to accommodate Iran and even
join the Iran new coalition the Middle
East Turkey Syria Hezbollah and Hamas
wouldn't I be better off in terms of our
of my survival what would your response
be
well the response would be look we've
been talk to you privately for some
years about the need for reform and
you've made number of public statements
about your intentions to do this or that
with elections with the civil society
etc and you haven't done it how about
starting it's not a crash I don't think
it's a real possibility of joining
should I join up with Iran and they are
Shia after all and you know my sister
doesn't I don't let him marry there's a
there's a real deep feeling in the
countries you mentioned about sunday she
attentions but you know they've had
complaints about us for decades it's we
did abandon the shower we we pull the
Marines out of Lebanon and catastrophes
followed all your American fault but
when it comes to friends like those in
the Arabian Peninsula and Jordan they
have talked of reform Saudi Arabia was
launching municipal elections they had
around and the next round was postponed
now for some reason they've decided to
have a next round they're feeling
pressure and sure they're going to blame
us and the example of Mubarak is a good
one we were damned rude to Mubarak the
way it was done in my opinion but the
assessment was obviously he's finished
with his own people and we're not going
to get between him and his own people
but they're all sorts of things they can
do and they may be no every regime as if
you will a shelf life they they may be
running out of time in some of those
running out of time from absolute
monarchy say to some form of
constitutional monarchy why not let's
move because you see what happens when
you don't move you end up either leaving
or shooting your own people that's what
I would say but you know one might know
to their complaints about withdrawal
from Iraq or Afghanistan that the
glasses have full the United States
invested eight or so years in tremendous
effort in Iraq it recently boosted its
effort in Afghanistan tremendously and I
don't think any American ever promised
that it would provide indefinite
protection and solutions to the problems
of the clients that it's tried to help
this way and certainly just to add that
if this if this Arab leader you're
talking to you happen to be Prime
Minister Maliki the response would be
very easy because you could simply say
well there's an opportunity to
renegotiate the status of forces
agreement that's due to expire at the
end of this year there's been a lot of
talk about that there was somewhat an
appreciation that that was one
possibility when the agreement came to a
close and for a variety of reasons which
I can understand but still Prime
Minister Maliki has not asked for a
renegotiation of this the Obama
administration has chosen largely to say
we would be open to a request to
renegotiate the treaty but we haven't
gotten one so that's where it seems to
have ended of course you never know what
you don't know but I'm fairly confident
that that's kind of the stalemate Moloch
you doesn't want to ask openly and
transparently and the Obama
administration doesn't feel it can move
without that request and so certainly in
this instance you could say well here's
one thing you could do if you're
interested in preserving American
influence in the region this would be
one way of building the partnership I
would just reinforce with what the what
the ambassador said about reform in
these own countries the lesson I think
that many of these leaders might take
from Egypt and Mubarak if the lesson is
that they take
America turned its back on Mubarak I can
understand that that's how they're
seeing it the reality is i think it's
not that america turned its back on
mubarak it is that blue barks people
turned their back on mubarak and that's
certainly if you have a million of your
citizens or half a million you were
citizens out on the streets that we're
not going to be in a position to uphold
a government against that kind of
popular opposition so i think the lesson
would be a very wrong lesson to learn if
that's the lesson they learned from
egypt is that America led its friends
down rather than the absence of reform
exactly as you said the absence of
reform had led mubarak to an
unsustainable position in which nothing
including us support could save it then
it the regime from you know um in the
Middle East a lot of it was a certainly
anti totalitarian but also people are
starving all over the world people are
starving and all our money is going to
military and strategic while all over
the world 14 million children are dying
of starvation the waters dirty and all
our money is going to what we consider
protection while ordinary people die and
nobody we're not talking about that I
mean isn't safety in the world that
people stay alive that you don't see
your children die in your arms and you
don't hear that said I mean that's a lot
of the Middle East was anti totalitarian
but also their children are starving
they have no jobs i mean the
unemployment rate in the world is is in
the stratosphere in the united states
also so where the choices you make on
what you consider security is it for
military industrial or is it for
ordinary people and we've met not really
made that choice i think in the right
direction from your generations maybe
forever well security is that children
don't die I mean and I do have a job and
you
to be thrown out of your house and
that's never part of the dialogue who I
would say that's probably more of the
dialogue today than it has been and in
these countries that we're talking about
because you're the lesson the the
lessons that a lot of these governments
have taken away have to do with the need
to be more responsive to their citizen
needs that as we've talked about today
and in other settings that the impetus
for these for these movements have been
has been largely domestic and it has had
an element of political demands but also
a very strong economic element and
that's one of the commonalities of what
we're seeing is just these very very
serious demographic pressures and these
very very serious economic problems
which are only going to get worse so I
think you do have governments which you
know maybe for the first time some of
them not for the first time I think
Saudi Arabia has been very aware of
these issues but realize that providing
more unemployment providing more
services for people actually has a
bearing on their longevity trouble is
more food and more wealth tends to make
more challenges come against the
regime's it's one of the unwritten laws
so I would like to take a little bit
longer perspective on wider perspective
in the sense of in the future we're
going to possibly see a stronger China
we're going to possibly see a stronger
Russia and America seems to be very
focused on isolating Iran and preventing
it from having a regional influence and
now if such a policy kind of continues
and were not able to limit Iran and we
won't take a military intervention
because of you know three wars and
possibly the ramifications of a military
attack on Iran as to other countries in
the region we might see a situation in
like 20-30 years where Iran which is
more confident which is positioned in
the region has close cooperation with
Russia and China and you know their
hostility between the two nations
use at that point which could at that
point be against American interest and
even Israeli interest so would you think
at some point the strategic outlook for
the long term it might be aligned in a
bit that we would accept Iran as a
regional player and you know just like
China has its own in SPF influence here
on would have his own sphere of
influence but at the same time I
possibly benefiting from a more positive
relationship with the country which for
the past 30 years we have had a
consistent policy towards and we haven't
really gained much benefit from that
policy it's coming it's coming it's
going to be hard to shift to attitudes
only ran at one point when the Iraq
fighting was pretty high low pretty
intense I actually heard some in
Washington saying what business has Iran
got in doing anything with Iraq as if
Iraq was our backyard and not Iran's so
it is yeah it's determined to play a
larger role in the region and we should
be thinking about ways to to deal with
that it's a talented people it's got a
long history a great culture etc and
they feel they they've been ignored and
some at least of their troublemaking is
attention catching don't think you can
deal without us but it's it's going to
take a lot of unwinding of American
policies about Iran about terrorism etc
I hate to jump in because that was
almost giving you the opportunity to end
on an upbeat note which I was like to do
okay um I actually think this this issue
of Iran's role in the region is the
hardest piece of and it's not so much in
fashion but not too long ago as
compassion to talk about the grand
bargain what's the grand bargain that's
going to resolve the issues between the
United States and Iran in the
international community and this piece
to me seems to be in my limited
interaction with the Iranians the most
important piece of the puzzle to them is
just their ability to be a dominant
regional player and it's very hard for
me i think if we say we were in a room
in a small group and we are sort of we
had people from every country in the
Gulf or the region and said like what's
what's an acceptable role I think that
there's it's a maybe a potentially null
set between what Iran envisions as being
an appropriate role for it in the region
and what not just the US but really the
rest of the Gulf and the region think is
an appropriate role for Iran in the
region I actually asked this of a recent
not current Iranian official and he said
well the Gulf fifty fifty fifty percent
american fifty percent Iranian I thought
even if you got an American
administration that thought that we
could have some kind of coordinated 5050
with the Iranians hmm Churchill
installed yes yeah that uh that
certainly you're not with us you're
against us in any in any case I just
think that this is this is a real
stumbling block to any kind of
diplomatic resolution to their Iran
peace with the current government in
Tehran to say I've heard that too from
Iranian sand in a meeting and they're
not in their not-too-distant past with
probably the same Iranians you know you
were meeting with um there was some you
know really astonishing just astounding
statement of disregard for the states on
the Arab side of the Gulf it was it it
was something to the effective well why
are you raising that I mean what is that
going to do with anything and then of
course one responds well you know
they're our allies or you know close
friends and countries and sovereignty
and all badness and the look of
stupefaction you know on the on the
Iranian side to these points was just
remarkable I think that's that is that
is really an obstacle the other obstacle
I mean in the near term is Iranian
domestic politics which I think will
make the kind of rapprochement or even
steps towards one that we're talking
about quite unlikely and don't don't
underestimate the problems of domestic
politics in Iran the the regime is
systematically purging the older
generation out of the university's out
of the bureaucracy and bringing in the
young people from the villages from the
small towns who did not leave Iran for
any part of their education and they're
obviously trying to put together a
lasting mindset there in favor of the
regime as it is they are very determined
to perpetuate their system one last
question for each of you if you had a
chance to get Barack Obama John Boehner
Harry Reid and all of the potential
Republican presidential candidates in a
row
and they said they had time for a minute
from you about what was most important
for them to think about in the Middle
East and you remember that they probably
most of them think less than two minutes
a day about these problems what would
you choose to say to them as sort of the
top thing that they would not have
thought about that they should think
about
does it
I should have told you beforehand Oh
smells great I just thought keep keep
listening keep your ears open you were
surprised in January and tuna she was
surprised in February in Cairo a lot of
surprises still still ahead out there
but stick by you know the principles the
values that we have as Americans and
then maybe we may find a lot in common
not necessarily in the form that these
governments will eventually settle into
but in the way they want to share in a
pluralistic society that go with your
hedging strategy well it in anticipate
and in fact that was what what I would
have said well one of the two things I
would have said because the second part
which is really just a coda really to
what Dick said stems from my mid v8 of
envy my bad mid v8 of envy because when
everything was going haywire in Egypt
and negative was asked at a press
conference well what do you think he
said the Egyptian government and the
Egyptian people have issues they're
trying to work them out I wish them both
luck and the reason I'm envious is
because um this it's really implicit in
the coda that I would suggest to what
dick is said which is let's try not to
make this about us let things play out
as much as we can without making them
about us that is without making that
about the US
and I guess just in that elevator that
I'm in with all these people I would
probably say that the events that we're
seeing in the Middle East can very well
be in the interest of the United States
and its allies but that in the short and
medium term to expect a lot of
instability that there will be a lot of
temptations for America to hang back and
there'll be lots of exhortation zvao how
America isn't wanted in the region and I
would argue in fact that America will
remain critical in the region but it has
to learn how to maneuver in a very
different way and in learning how to
maneuver in a different way it should be
very very cautious about the application
of military force and should look to
have the primary means of engaging these
countries and these people be through
civilian power through diplomacy through
economics and that that America will
probably find if it uses those as
primary tools of engagement in the
region they will probably find that
American influence is very welcome well
behalf of Saltzman institute I want to
thank all of you and the prior panelists
to for a an interesting and challenging
day your front do you have anything you
want to say and passing
I just want to say thank you to DEKRA
for having cooperating and having a
football conference and I wish America
all the best in the Middle East as well
as elsewhere